i've heard you talk about apophis
now we just talked about uh smaller
asteroids
uh house house size house size asteroids
hitting the atmosphere some if they are
metal oh by the way
i don't mean like bill gates sized
houses they're like regular people
regular people houses
but they would some would break up some
being more bound tightly
or being more tightly bound would
continue on yes
now with that in mind how big
would an asteroid like apophis be
and since these house-sized asteroids
would not
wipe out earth what would be an
extinction level
event apophis if we know how big apophis
is so it's not how
big a profits would be is how big is it
it's about 300 meters across
and if you if you sort of measure that
out with a corresponding
sizes of structures it's about the size
of the
fully open rose bowl pasadena so the
field plus all the seats
that would plunk nicely into that like
an egg sits in an egg cup
yeah so that would uh if that hits it
would
the most likely place would hit would be
the pacific ocean and would raise a
50-foot tsunami that would wipe
clean the west coast of north america
have a nice day
that's okay but no one has to die
because we
we would predict when this happens we
would know it this is a good thing about
the laws of physics
you can predict the future nice in ways
that protect your life
extend your life expectancy well we
can't say no one would die because there
would be at least a handful of surfers
who would say
stupid surfers dude i got to do stupid
surfers and stupid cameramen
no stupid uh weatherman right who's
trying to get the camera guy too close
to the surf
exactly two dead people in there so you
clear out the west coast and then you
watch it happen and it could be a quite
a spectacle
so that's not extinction level either
it's just very damaging
we'll do a trillion dollars worth of
damage we know the size of an asteroid
that would do
very bad things and it's about a
kilometer across a little more than a
half a mile across
that size asteroid would disrupt
civilization
that's it no it won't leave it's extinct
but it could take out
it could disrupt the food chain the
transportation channels
things that we rely on for modern living
apocalypse
yes so we would need to rebuild
what our modern culture of human life on
earth
would be and that would be about a
kilometer about a kilometer across right
and you get to 10 kilometers then you've
got
a 10 kilometer size you've got
extinction level asteroid
and how big would the asteroid have been
for the dinosaurs dinosaur
was about the size of mount everest yeah
so that's about 10 kilometers oh my
goodness yeah oh yeah
all right cool yeah now that's much
smaller than earth
and in the old days we thought it would
just leave a crater and you were just
unlucky enough to be where the crater
hit
right then you know but we learned that
the stuff it thrusts into the atmosphere
blocks the sun
cloaks the earth knocks out the base of
the food chain because
because photosynthesis can unfold and
a wave of extinction percolates across
the tree of life
there you go people have a nice day
that's beautiful sleep well
sleep well